now in case you hadn't realized this
year marks the 40th anniversary of Star
Wars can you believe it it's been 40
years and I still look so young yeah and
now it's my pleasure to bring to the
stage the president of Lucasfilm
Kathleen Kennedy I'm sure like me you
can't quite believe that it's been 40
years I know some of you not quite that
long but for those of you that were
around in 1977 it is truly going to be
an awesome celebration your passion your
dedication and your love of Star Wars
you guys have no idea how that inspired
us every single day the greatest honor
for me is to acknowledge the man whose
collective genius has brought us all
together today
[Applause]
please welcome
[Applause]
I own up George Lucas
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I mean it's absolutely incredible we're
celebrating 40 years of Star Wars how do
you feel how does that make you feel um
apart from old well the shock the shock
was I hired you when you were 11 years
old yeah and and now you have gray hair
that let me know what 40 years is cost
you're mine back all the way back to the
early 70s I want to know about that
moment you first came up with Star Wars
where were you what was going on the
idea was more I would like to make a
action movie which is more like a
Saturday matinee cereal that I enjoyed
as a kid but imbue it with mythological
psychological motifs because we don't
have any of those today so I said well I
want to take these two things and put
them together the idea was simply to do
a high adventure film that I loved when
I was a kid with meaningful
psychological themes and now it's my
pleasure to introduce Star Wars rebels
executive producer and supervising
director Dave Maloney
[Applause]
[Music]
so I am a fan so I mean it's easy for me
to answer I mean you look out here and
the the TV series let us do something
kind of unique which was we were on all
the time
week to week so we were able to give
fans a Star Wars storytelling experience
every week and in today's media world
you know they want people wanted to
connect with us more and more and more
and the actors on comas were really good
about being out there being open with
people connecting with the fans it's a
way of you know making this the
community that you see and it's
something that we respect at Lucasfilm
we know how much people love us how
important it is to them so it's
important to reach out to them and make
you guys feel as much a part of it as we
can it's I got to say it's been a real
privilege for me to be a part of this in
any small way that I have been to be up
here with you guys you know because I
grew up watching your film please
welcome Ian McDermott and Hayden
Christensen
[Applause]
[Music]
tell us why it was like working with Ian
a hugely experienced actor were you
intimidated at all Oh working with with
Ian was was just a real treat and a
privilege I mean everyone knows that
he's such a amazing actor but he's also
an incredibly generous actor and and
really kind of took me under his wing
and and and was just very caring and
giving and and I owe a lot of what I was
able to accomplish in Episode three to
being able to work with Ian we met very
briefly over lunch time with Richard
Marquand this is of course Return of the
Jedi and I was very pleased to meet them
both thrilled of course and then we set
up a light goodbyes and I went back home
and the phone was ringing my agent said
you've got the part
I said hello that's great what's the
part and he went you know agents do
leafing through piles of you know papers
and they say oh apparently he's called
the Emperor of the universe oh so I
thought oh well I guess were doing it
then so now I'm going to invite a few
more friends to join us here on stage
please and I'm sure you will help me
welcome a protocol droid a Wookiee and
the Baron of Cloud City Anthony Daniels
P de Mayo and Billy Dee Williams
[Applause]
Wow welcome gentlemen the last time I
saw you three together you were dancing
up a storm in Ewok village and here you
are yeah and I'm still embarrassed about
that moment there we were flying out to
Death Valley to go on the road to
Jabba's palace
do you remember right little everything
and they were setting up this this box
with a mirror window in it to make the
max painting of Jabba's palace and once
they were doing that I kind of you know
walked along sort of going young Lando
Calrissian never returned from this
awful place and suddenly behind in bbbbb
and there was you guys Phoebe Phoebe it
was a cutest moment ever
I just loved it tell me how are you and
Chewie similar and well with the same
height starters good answer and I have
blue eyes which was specific on a
certain gentleman drawings so and what I
need
do you share any of series
characteristics anything that he any
good skills
yeah I can I couldn't maintain the focus
honey yeah oh yeah you take three plugs
out and drain you oh good what was your
inspiration for Chewbacca well the
stories were all true which is I had a
large dog named Indiana is a Malibu
Laska Malamute and he would ride around
in the car in the front seat no driving
not drive out and you know I love that
image of driving with his large because
he was when he sat in the car was bigger
than I was and so that was where I said
that would be a fun character for Star
Wars for me I was pretty established as
more so than most of the actors that
were in the film and I was doing some
interesting things with my life in my
career
and so when I had the opportunity to
work with George Lucas I mean I thought
that was like going straight to heaven
[Laughter]
no I'm seriously seriously it was a a
wonderful extraordinary experience that
I'm very happy to them ever had it must
feel pretty rewarding to be surrounded
by one two three dare I say four of your
greatest character creations why don't
we go crazy and make it five Laderman
Mark Hamill
[Applause]
well I can never get over the fans they
are supportive there with you in good
times bad times they're more supportive
than my actual family because they
criticize me all the time okay but
listen to be honest with you meeting you
and hearing your stories and how the
movies affected your lives or inspired
you or you met your future wife or
husband the way it's being passed down
to the next generation
it's really moving and certainly nothing
I've ever taken for granted I'm always
just stunned at the passion that has
lasted all these years I'm sitting here
as white Davis but also a fan and I mean
I don't know you guys but when we've got
George Lucas here we've got c-3po we've
got Lando ferreted let's do that and the
Skywalker I mean it doesn't get much
more epic than this does it or actually
maybe it does
ladies gentlemen please welcome Harrison
Ford
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we'll take a few minutes to calculate
the coordinates no no no sorry we left
out the navicomputer take a few minutes
for the navicomputer to calculate ah I
said to George you can type this stop
stop but you can't say it move your
mouth while you're talking while you're
typing it and I couldn't say it it took
me like 15 takes
how did Star Wars impact you 40 years
ago what does it mean to you to that oh
it's made no difference in my life
whatsoever it was the beginning of
incredible ride actually wasn't the very
beginning the very beginning was also
with George and that was a part in
American Graffiti and then I went back
to doing carpentry work and and then
Along Came George once again pulled me
up above my bootstraps and put me to
work
an extraordinary event that we all
celebrate and it's been a good ride they
got the part because in the end I asked
him I said this is about spaceships and
flying and stuff like that who says I
said you know to fly yeah
I said fly yeah land Jorge when did it
click for you that this cast was
something extra special ticket you know
it you don't notice it until you're
shooting right you know you can have the
most really cast in the world but they
have a story to tell and the story that
we had to tell was more than sufficient
it was full of humor and emotion and
conflict and it was a it was a brilliant
invention of a mythology that that has
sustained interest for over 40 years and
and that's made up of whole cloth out of
whole cloth bye bye bye George and an
actor without a story to tell us you
know might as well go home so it was a
brilliant opportunity for all certainly
for me and on behalf of all the fans
here in the room and throughout the
world watching via live stream thank you
each and every one of you for your
contribution to Star Wars later
gentlemen who can make you an American
tour
thank you
a Paul guy soviet-american when I cast
it I said I really want somebody young
to play the part I want somebody very
young and when Kari came in she was that
character she was very strong very smart
very funny very bold very tough and you
know there really wasn't much of a
question there are not very many people
like her you know they're one in a
billion I'm in a mirror a little bit of
that I think that there was no greater
honor than that of working with the late
and truly great Carrie Fisher she was
unlike anyone you've known unlike anyone
in this room her humor her insights her
brilliance when you associate Princess
Leia you realize that was Carrie she was
not only be remembered forever by those
who were lucky enough to know her but
she will be remembered forever even by
those who are not old enough yet to say
the word may the force be with you
someone who has known Carrie her entire
life who the world has revolved around
Star Wars and is uniquely suited to give
us wonderful insight on this remarkable
woman it's her daughter Billie please
welcome Billy Roy
[Applause]
my mom used to say she never knew where
Princess Leia ended and Carrie Fisher
began she went from being an unknown
actress the daughter of Debbie Reynolds
and Eddie Fisher to Princess Leia a
character synonymous with the idea of
the ultimate strong woman a soldier a
fighter a beyond capable independent
sensible woman in control of her own
destiny a rebel who resisted the norm
she was imperfect in many ways but her
imperfections and willingness to speak
about them are what made her more than
perfect my mom like Leia
wasn't ever afraid to speak her mind and
say things that might have made most
people uncomfortable but not me and not
you that was why she loved you because
you accepted and embraced all of her the
strong soldier of a woman she was
and also the vulnerable side of her who
opened who often openly fought her own
dark side knowing early on that we all
have a dark side of our own whatever it
may be but she knew that it wasn't about
the fight that you were fighting but how
you fought it the way you resisted no
one could have known what this one's
little dream of a movie would eventually
become and what it would mean to
millions worldwide mostly not her but in
our world Star Wars
ultimately became our religion our
family in our way of life and I wanted
to be here with all of you because I
know that many of you feel the same way
when she surrounded herself with fans at
celebrations like this she never felt
more at home she could spend hours
talking to people and learning about
their lives and how Star Wars and Leia
touched them the same way it touched us
if left to her own devices she would
have always been the last person to
leave the convention center having met
and had a shared Carrie moment with
every single person there nothing about
her was a performance she loved you she
loved these movies she loved the people
she got to make them with and she loved
this incredible character she got to
create this force called Leia
[Applause]
she taught me three important things one
thing all mothers should teach their
daughters general Kenobi
years ago you served my father in the
Clone Wars now he begged you to help him
in his struggle against the Empire
I regret that I am unable to present my
father's request to you in person but my
ship has fallen under attack and I'm
afraid my mission to bring you to
Alderaan has failed I have placed
information vital to the survival of the
rebellion into the memory systems of
this r2 unit
my father will know how to retrieve it
you must see this droid safely delivered
to him on Alderaan this is our most
desperate hour help me obi-wan Kenobi
you're my only hope
[Applause]
secondly she taught me that it's life
isn't funny then it's just true and that
is unacceptable
and finally I learned by knowing her
that the most evolved person is
seemingly a contradiction they are both
the strongest and the most vulnerable
person in the room and that was her that
is Leia thank you for loving her and
carrying on what she stands for and
beyond grateful
[Applause]